how many individual elements have to be
created to make a movie look realistic
apparently 72 thousand animation has
come
so far over the years with more
innovative and sophisticated
technologies
which ryan the last dragon scenes looked
so realistic at one point that they
actually had to be toned down so they
weren't so harsh
what special technique mimicking camera
lenses is a major contributor to the
realism of all these animated movies
class sponsor kanji today's special is
to go frozen one and two were released
six years apart but if we look at all
the details in the animation
well let's just say we're wildly
impressed by the improvement of
technology
which is saying a lot since the first
frozen already
created scenes like this we're trapped
the intricacy and details included in
the animation are major contributors as
to why frozen 2 looked so much more
realistic than the first
check out these details on elsa's dress
every stitch is visible
and these 3d jewels we're impressed
that's a north uldra scarf
what while on his outfit may not be as
bedazzled
we're still dazzled by it the detailing
with all these small pieces of fabric
not only do we have tiny details we also
have
tiny shadows these are intricate details
that we don't really notice unless we're
paying much attention to it
but are definitely a major contributor
as to why it comes across as so real
if we look at the sisters hair we not
only notice a difference in the texture
and quality of the animated hair
but the two also have more mature styles
than they did in the first film
combining the accurately aged styles
with the very detailed strands of hair
makes them look so realistic
not only does it look real but it also
moves like actual hair
this was all thanks to a creation
software called beast
these two are definitely hair goals now
as unrealistic as a horse made out of
water might be
frozen makes us believe it definitely
could be real
what's fantastic about this is how
enchanting it all looks while bringing
loads of realistic details
the way the water moves and flows as the
knock feels so real
not to mention for a creature with so
few modes of communication
the subtle ways the eyes and ears shift
let us know exactly what was going on
it's the details of both look and
character combined that really bring
these movies of fantasy to life
of course while we're on the subject of
water
let's take a minute to appreciate how
breathtaking these images are
the way the sand looks after being
touched by water and how that shifts
the subtle ways the light shift across
water and sand
notice the very subtle mist and spray
details they really make the shot
we see this grand image but it remains
within reason for believability
then of course we have gail everyone's
favorite gust
disney brought us animated air using a
new software they developed called swoop
that helped them to really create a
realistic seeming body
the animators went so far as to go
skydiving for inspiration and to better
understand how
wind moved and interacted with the body
oh and when they breathe
yeah breathing their bodies move exactly
the ways ours really do
it certainly adds more power to these
shots a vocal coach was key to bringing
the breathing techniques used to life
so elsa's hair looked real her outfits
looked real
her breathing looked real so when she
runs
every tiny movement in her feet is seen
thanks to the multiple control points
oh no what now
the software used to bring water to life
in frozen two was also used in moana
the software was so good that the
intensity of certain scenes looked so
real that the animators actually had to
pull back on it so there wasn't too much
of a disconnect between the characters
and the environments
how about moana's gorgeous hair well we
have a software called quicksilver to
thank for that
it helped to create the natural and
realistic moving hair we see here
each strand of hair is animated how
about these island landscapes
they look so realistic because they are
real the team actually sculpted some of
these out by hand as we can see
it wouldn't be moana without everyone's
favorite demigod maui
animated films often modeled the
characters after the people who voiced
them but doing it with such a specific
and well-known figure as the rock made
it that much stronger
enjoy the island maui
stop first off
huge props to the 400 person animating
team who created this entire film from
home in isolation
every land and setting was put together
by combining all the work each artist
sent from home
from the layout to the rigging all the
way to the animation
remember all that impressively looking
real water we saw in moana and frozen
too
well as we can see it all got even
better in raya and the last dragon
these scenes make up for some of the 72
000 individual elements animated for the
movie
raya and numari's fierce outfits were
created with a new draping based design
that's why we can see these subtle
motions in the way their clothes move
that really brings them to life
the cinematic techniques they used were
inspired by naturalistic live-action
movies
major contributors to this are the
details of light the way shots are
composed and framed
to the actual lens styles used to bring
realistic vibes to the film
the animation in riot and the last
dragon at one point looked so realistic
that it came across
as harsh and it was too much so they had
to pull back on the details
the intensity is still there but it's
less graphic which helps to make it a
more family friendly flick
oh mighty sisu who's that
we still tear up when we think about
this beautiful movie
what makes it extra impressive is how it
manages to bring realistic looks to
loads of meta and theoretical ideas
in addition to the realistic details of
the real world
we find ourselves totally immersed in
their universe similar to the multiple
control feet we saw in frozen
highly detailed work was put into making
joe's hands and fingers move
realistically while playing the piano
first they animate and outline the
general hand placement and then add
every nuanced detail we see looking
really closely
so how did the gray beyond and the grape
before seem like they could be real
fantastical as they were notice how
these scenes are a bit blurred compared
to the scenes in the city
this simple detail managed to make the
hypothetical places like a world we
could imagine
part of the realism of these settings
came from the material it was based on
the lightest solid synthetic material on
earth aerogel
is it h e double hockey sticks
why does joy always look so bubbly
figuratively and literally
well if we look closely we notice that
she is actually made of what appears to
be
tiny sparkling bubbles when we see her
glow well
that just perfects her look and energy
that energy is exactly the aim since
that's what they realistically represent
joy's eyes are also major contributors
it's no shock to learn that
her eyes actually had two times as many
controls than
any pixar character before remember this
chilling shaky cam scene
the style of shooting was a huge
contributor to making the movie feel
real
not only was the style similar the
actual lens looks are imitated by the
lenses used in non-animated films
pixar also used camera capture
techniques to animate the film
and by this time they were pros since
they first used it in creating the short
film blue umbrella
check out these two aspect ratios notice
how the image of toy story 4 looks less
cartoony somehow
this is just one example of how much the
technology and ideas have developed
notice how dusty it is in the antique
shop that's right
dusty look at all those detailed
particles of dust
alongside these cobwebs it definitely
makes the whole world feel way closer to
our own
of course the animation of these faces
were also major steps forward
considering how they looked in the first
film
just look at the life in woody's eyes
the more realistic the animation we see
the more the films have moved us the
fact that the environments and
characters we see on screen are
reflecting our real world more and more
is definitely a major contributor to how
we watch and connect with these films
considering how rapidly the technology
has and continues to develop
we can't wait to see what new
innovations will be used for the
creation of luca
and encanto